er ist das erste corona kabinett seit
der bund dem bund länder gipfel im
vergangenen mai gend lich sollte es
heute um die aktuellen zahlen in erster
linie gehen aber stellt sich jetzt
heraus dass man sich doch vor allem
darum kümmern muss wie eigentlich
zwischen den bundesländern mit den hot
spots umgegangen wird die jetzt
hinzugekommen sind seit diesem gipfel
und da spielen neben kleineren spot wie
in hamm in nordrhein-westfalen eben
jetzt drei größere eine rolle
inzwischen sind es vier gewonnen sind
vier bezirke in berlin die zum hotspot
geworden sind dh in denen gibt es in den
letzten sieben tagen mehr als 50
neuinfektionen pro 100.000 einwohner
diese sind in kreuzberg friedrichshain
tempelhof-schöneberg berlin mitte und
neukölln
diese vier sind problembezirke und die
frage ist wie gehen jetzt andere
bundesländer damit um das problem dass
jetzt aufgetaucht ist ist dass schleswig
holstein zum beispiel und auch
rheinland-pfalz diese bezirke als risiko
bezirke ein risikogebiet eingestuft
haben und das hat zur folge wer von dort
nach schleswig holstein oder nach
rheinland pfalz einreist muss sich
zumindest theoretisch in 14 tägige
quarantäne begeben
also wir haben wieder einen
flickenteppich im ganzen land wer jetzt
wie mit dieser situation umgeht markus
söder hatte dazu gesagt er wünsche sich
doch eine eher gesamtdeutsche lösung
obwohl er natürlich weiterhin für den
föderalismus ist wie realistisch ist es
dass man jetzt damit auf dass jeder sein
eigenes ding macht damit auch vielleicht
einfach die menschen die bürger besser
verstehen was sie jetzt tun müssen was
jetzt ihren pflichten sind ja eigentlich
dachte man glaube ich man hätte eine
einheitliche lösung indem man eben sagt
egal letztlich ob es ein hotspot
irgendwo in frankreich oder innerhalb
deutschlands ist wer aus einem hotspot
gebiet kommt bekommt bestimmte
beschränkungen auferlegt bislang hat man
nicht damit gerechnet dass jedenfalls
nicht vor augen gehabt dass diese
hotspots auch mitten in deutschland
liegen können und das große problem
dabei ist zb mecklenburg vorpommern
sieht ganz berlin als möglichen hotspot
aber noch nicht an den ganz berlin
zusammengerechnet ist man derzeit noch
unter dieser 50er grenze liegen so bei
38 alle berliner
gemeinsam und rheinland pfalz und
schleswig holstein haben sich jetzt
ausbildungen
nein wir rechnen diese einzelnen bezirke
als einzelne hotspots und damit ist
berlin sozusagen aufgeteilt in
risikogebiet und nicht risikogebiet
jedenfalls aus sicht dieser beiden
länder es könnten noch weitere folgen um
die sache richtig auf die spitze zu
treiben rheinland pfalz hat bislang den
vierten hinzugekommenen bezirk in berlin
nämlich tempelhof-schöneberg noch gar
nicht mit eingerechnet
das könnte im laufe des tages noch
passieren denn die meldungen vom robert
koch institut das auch in diesem
berliner stadtbezirk die zahlen über 50
liegen
die kamen erst heute morgen mehr
nachrichten und breaking news nur bei
bate schau dich jedes nächste video an
und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren